Hi, Max conference. I'm Mats Ledele. I'm the maintainer of the Knower Herbperboly together
with the author Bob Weiner. The title of the talk is "Fun things with Knower Herbperboly".
And that I intend to cover a different set of small things that is in the package.
So this will not be a tutorial of Herbperboly. For that you have to look for other sources.
And this is a short talk. So let's get started with the first thing.
Also we're going to talk about scrolling and with the subtitle using the end of line.
If you need to Herbperboly, you need to know about the action key and the assist key.
The action key is bound to meta-return and the assist key is bound by default to meta-return
with the prefix orbit. So both of these keys are used for performing actions on different
contexts. And in this case we'll look what happens when you use it on the end of the line.
So I have here the tutorial, the MX tutorial, and we see here a line inserting and deleting.
I move there and put the cursor on the end of the line. I then hit meta-return, the
action key, and it's moved to the top of the window. If I want to move it to the last row
on the window, I can press Ctrl U and then meta-return. So I use the assist key.
If I repeatedly hit meta-return, it will scroll. So the first time it moves to the top of
the window. But if I add the top of the window, it's meta-return again, it scrolls.
Now move to the next thing. So the next thing is to compose an email from Manares. Another
is the style of username at the main. Let's look into that. So here I have entered the file
in the MX distribution version control EL and at its top it has a lot of different email
addresses from contributors. This is in principle a normal text file. And by placing the cursor
over one of these addresses and hitting the action key, I probably identify that it's an
email address and tries to open or opens the email composo with that using that email address.
And if we go to the scotch buffer, prepare another name there. So just to demonstrate the
box in an buffer the same way. The next found thing is insert implicit link. I'm going
to give you an example with email, I'm to share an implicit link with someone. An implicit
link is a text pattern, just as we saw with the email address, something that I probably
recognize is just by how the text looks. So here we have the example. We have started
writing an email to the user at the main. And in the other window below the cursor control
EL file is open. It's now opened within the search path, the load path. So that's why
it's compressed. And I want to tell my friend about the credit section. So first the cursor
is placed here at your credit section. I move over to another window and I use the hyperbole
menu system. So by hitting control H, H, I go into the menu system. I press I for getting
an I button, implicit button, I press L for getting a, creating a link. And there you have
the link. So what does that link mean? Well, it means that in the low for hyperbole email
actually finds a special. If there are in the load path, they will use this short format.
And the end, you have the L for the line number 24 and the C for the column. So if I hit the
action key on this line, you can see that the cursor moves over to the credit section.
You can remove that file just to make sure that it works and move the cursor a little bit
and hit after turning again or meta return and we moved over there. So it, I mean, given
that the receiver has a similar setup with emacs, et cetera, they will, that link will
work there as well. Hi, emacs conference. It's a new recording day. The sun is shining.
I'm wearing a new t-shirt, but we're still cracking on with fun things in hyperbole.
Our next subject is window grid. So with hyperbole, it's easy to create a grid of windows.
I'm going to show how you can do that and also moving on. I'm going to show how you can
use the red or eye buffer to select what buffers to show in the grid. And I will also show
how you can save configuration for use later. You reach the window grid functionality
through the hyperbole menu system. So control H, H, screen. There you have to submenus frame
control, window control. The red functionality is part of both of these submenus. You can
select either, but I go with window control here. And down to the left, we see the add character
and the grid of windows. So hit add. And I'm prompted with the number of columns and rows
for the window grid, which I select 3 by 3 grid. And we get the 3 by 3 grid. It's populated
with buffers. I have loaded in emacs. So let's go back to the square buffer. Now using
all those keystrokes for the menu system is a little bit cumbersome. So there is a shortcut
control C at and if I use that control C at, I get immediately prompted with the number
of rows and columns. If I use a prefix org 0, control U 0, control C at, I get also prompted
with what type of buffers I want to populate in my grid. So let's select emacs list mode.
And again with the 3 by 3 grid. And here you see all the grids or the whole grid is populated
with the emacs list buffers. To get even finer control, you can go into iBuffer and I have
pre-selected here all the emacs list files. I have, so let's pick a few like I marked them
like this. Let's pick three or maybe pick four. And then I had the add sign and then it automatically
shows tool by tool grid with the selected buffers. We can go in again and maybe maybe select
a few more. And the same thing hit add and it now becomes a 3 by 2 grid with these buffers.
The same thing is possible through the grid. So let's just mark quite a few here and
then hit add and then it populates it with all the buffers and you see that if it's not enough
buffer to fill the whole grid, there are blank grids or tangles in the grid. Now going back
and forth like this, maybe if you want to work on some file and then go over to dear it again
to select this can be a little bit cumbersome. You maybe are prepared, agreed with the buffers
you want to have there. Then the heart probably comes with a simple window configuration support
and you reach that the same way through the heart probably menus or controller hh and
window w for window and there you can hit save to save the configuration to ring of configurations.
So let's go back to like the scratch buffer again here and now we want to sort of bring up
our window configuration again so we hit control hh and window and yanking the configuration
and boom, there is the grid again. We're reaching the end of the talk. The last fun thing I want
to talk about is the heart probably support for select the thing and we'll show some use
of selections together with web search. So here I have brought up the new general public
license for just getting some text that I can show the select the thing functionality. So let's
move the cursor over the word versions and then I hit control c return which is bound for the
select the thing functionality. Then it selects the word that the cursor was at. If I hit it again
control c return it selects the line and again it selects the sentence and again the whole paragraph.
So that's a convenient way to extend your search source your selections rather in a buffer.
Looking at selection so you can use that from web search. Let's mark some text and then
hit control c / which is bound for the web search. Here you see the heart probably menu system
again. It's slightly customized with things that I use but the basic menus are the one supported by
heart probably. So let's look at searching .go and it then publish the prompt with the selection.
And I have configured it so it uses my Firefox for these searches.
Here we have the new general public license show. I can also show that for like me being not native
English speaker let's look what take away your freedoms means in Swedish so control c / and then
I hit translate. Take away your freedom. Yeah what's the translation for that? Using Google translate
I get it translated the Swedish. That was the whole talk.
We reached the end and thanks for listening. Bye.